Excusez-moi monsieur, je crois que vous vous trompez de voiture.
Plusieurs mails deux ans de suite pour avoir un rendez vous ?
Dites moi ce qui vous arrive ?
Je n'ai jamais vu un cas semblable.
Dites-moi ce qu'il s'est passé.
Ouvrez la porte !!!
On doit avoir de l'importance.
C'est qui ça ? Elle peut peut être nous aider !
On est là ! Aidez-nous !
Ne vous inquiétez pas, il sait pourquoi vous êtes ici.
Il lui est interdit de toucher à vous. Il le sait.
Je m'appelle Edwig, j'ai des chaussettes rouges.
Tu as quel âge ?
Le cerveau humain
est l'objet le plus complexe de l'univers.
La seule façon de se tirer d'ici, c'est que l'un d'eux décide de nous laisser sortir.
C'est toi la plus maligne ?
Tu pourrais nous aider Edwig ?
Okay...
Il y a une fenêtre dans ma chambre...
Tu veux bien nous la montrer ?
Regarde !
Là, elle est fermée,
Là, elle est ouverte.
T'as cru que c'était une vraie fenêtre ?
Et que tu pourrais t'en aller ?
Un individu à personnalités multiples
peut modifier sa physiologie
par la force de la pensée.
Quelqu'un va venir vous chercher.
Que se passera-t-il quand il libérera tout le potentiel de son cerveau ?
Il n'y a pas de limite à ce qu'il peut devenir.
Cette nuit est sacrée.
Vous allez être
en présence de quelque chose de plus grandiose.
Le monde... va comprendre maintenant...
La bête...
existe.
Elle a fait des choses horribles à des gens.
Elle va vous faire aussi des choses horribles.
SPLIT